on aurait voulu les croiser là-haut sur
les cimes on les a finalement rejoint en
bas entre les lignes Philippe chuchote à
Sylvain tous deux dans leur univers
celui des mots des voyages et de la
géographie moi je m'intéresse davantage
à ce qui n'est pas humain les règnes
végétaux animaux et minéraux
c'est pour ça que ça c'est mes rayons
ici c'est sans doute ce rapport à la
nature qui distingue le plus le père du
fils l’œil amusé la liberté de ton qu'on
lui connaît Philippe rétorque à Sylvain
avec beaucoup d'humour il a quand même
sur moi quelques centaines de milliers
d'années de retard parce que il vit un
peu comme un préhistorique moi je suis
très bourgeois il l'a dit lui c'est un
sauvage c'est tout c'est pas grave je
suis absolument un peu en avance mais il
me rattrapera il y a vraiment du sens de
l'homme ancien chez lui l'homme
préhistorique je peux nous dire
le tour du monde à 40 il s'est laissé
absorber par l'univers dans une cabane
de 9 m² en pleine taille sibérienne
ermite ou écrite il laisse infuser les
heures on s'intéresse beaucoup value
puisqu'il est original moi je suis
normal je serai chez moi dans un lit que
douillet
face à face étonnant il joue depuis
toujours paraît-il leurs différences
avec ce même génie du refus mondain
Philippe sauvage Sylvain citadin le père
montagnard le fils les Sims est une
passion venue des courses en altitude
des histoires alpines c'est là aussi
qu'il a trouvé une géographie dit-il qui
permettait d'intensifier rapidement
l'existence quand on grimpe une voie
qu'elle fasse que ce soit une petite
escalade de 200 mètres ou une grande
paroi de 1000 mètres on vit une vie en
condensée avec ses espoirs c'est danger
ses envies ses aspirations ces moments
de découragement et puis c'est
émerveillement c'était arrivé au sommet
c'est trop descente et là tout à coup on
a eu l'impression d'avoir volé à la mort
une petite vie en soi
ensemble ils ont grimpé là-haut face au
jet d'eau et puis tout s'est achevé sur
les planches histoire de transmission
nous avait-on dit qui sans aucun doute a
le goût de l'instant et du bonheur
[Musique]